ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation sur le ministre du jamais
vu
c'est ce que les agriculteurs nous ont
dit après avoir constaté les dégâts
considérables provoqués par la grêle
d'un autre département
ces dégâts ne concerne pas seulement la
drôme mais je souhaite associer à ma
question mes collègues de l'ardèche il
se présente bien sûr de l'isère de la
savoie et de la haute-savoie
ces départements n'ont pas eu l'honneur
de votre visite mais ils ont également
été très durement touchée c'est toute
une économie qui mise en balles les
agriculteurs et les viticulteurs ont
aujourd'hui besoin de la solidarité
nationale
sinon ils mettront la clé sous la porte
vous avez annoncé que l'état va déclarer
en situation de catastrophe naturelle et
de calamités agricoles ces départements
c'est indispensable mais monsieur le
ministre c'est loin d'être suffisant
pour venir efficacement en aide à ceux
qui ont tout perdu
la catastrophe naturelle n'a pas de ça
n'a de sens que pour les agriculteurs
qui sont assurés or tous ne le sont pas
loin s'en faut
en raison du coût prohibitif des primes
d'assurance quant à l'état de calamité
agricole exclut d'indemnisation de
nombreuses situations
monsieur le ministre si l'état ne fait
pas du cas par cas et la campagne pas
plus largement les agriculteurs nous
assisterons à des faillites mahatma
question que comptez-vous faire du
concret et d'efficace pour répondre à
toutes les situations de détresse
merci pour vous répondre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gilbert bouchet oui j'ai fait
deux départements sur les 5
pendant deux jours la drôme et l'isère
c'est déjà pas mal moi j'étais sur le
terrain dès ce week-end avec l'ensemble
des organisations
à agricole évidemment on peut toujours
polémiquer on peut toujours demander
toujours plus les bâtiments avec
catastrophes naturelles sont peuvent
être peuvent être remboursés par
l'assurance
c'est uniquement sur la récolte mais
pour les bâtiments heureusement ça
marche les bâtiments sont tous éventrée
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai déjà
répondu à monsieur colin tout à l'heure
j'ai l'intention dans les jours qui
viennent de réunir les principaux
acteurs pour mettre en route à partir
d'une feuille blanche
une réflexion je dis bien à part d'une
feuille blanche une réflexion sur
l'assurance récolte évidemment l'objet
n'est pas de rembourser donner de
l'argent aux véhicules terre ils veulent
vivre de leurs de leur travail
il faut éviter que les catastrophes mais
y en aura d'autres n'en doutons pas donc
l'objectif c'est d'arriver à faire en
sorte que de façon la plus solidaire
possible nous mettions une assurance
récolte
qu'ils soient accessibles ce qui n'est
pas forcément le cas aujourd'hui et qui
puisse permettre aux agriculteurs
lorsqu'ils sont touchés par des aléas
climatiques parce que un artisan un
industriel
son aire de travail c'est un bâtiment un
paysan son aire de travail
c'est le ciel et c'est la terre donc
c'est plus compliqué assuré il faut donc
recommencé totalement à 0 sans qu à
demain il n'y aura plus d'agriculteurs
ça sera fini notre indépendance et ne
sauverait souveraineté alimentaire parce
qu'ils ne pourront pas remontées chaudes
cheval ce chiffre exclut mire ainsi pour
redémarrer
moi j'ai vu des reculs teurs motivés
même ceux qui avaient tout perdu j'ai vu
des agriculteurs qui ont encore la force
de repartir mais aujourd'hui ils n'ont
plus les outils
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'engage
tous le monde agricole
tous les parlementaires loin de toutes
les discussions qui peuvent avoir lieu à
se lancer enfin dans la seule réponse
que nous pouvons apporter c'est une
assurance récolte accessible
intermédiaire à tout le monde
si nous ne faisons pas cela nous ne nous
en sortir a pas non sentiront pas mais
je veux remercier la région département
les intercoms pour la solidarité qu'ils
amènent dans cette dans cette aventure
là merci l'acier min
c'est mon souhait monsieur le ministre
est pour le présent c'est que ça urge
est qu'un maximum de personnes puissent
être indemnisés
qu'il s'agisse de particuliers ou de
professionnels avec la prise en compte
de toutes les problématiques liées et je
pense notamment aux bâtiments dont
certains sont recouverts d'amiante
ce qui complique les travaux de
réparation et alourdit considérablement
la facture et pour l'avenir au vu de
l'importance de ces phénomènes
climatiques
il faudra réfléchir et vous venez de le
dire ensemble à une refonte totale du
système assurantiel notamment pour les
agriculteurs je vous remercie